so in Sam's originally sent me an email
to do this course he said Ben can you
teach a 50-minute courts on management
and I immediately thought to myself wow
I just wrote a 300 page book on
management so that book was entirely too
long and I didn't actually have time to
candle at the 300 pages into 50 minutes
so like Mark Twain I didn't have time to
write a good short letter so I'm going
to write a long letter but in this case
I'm going to teach exactly one
management concept so one long thing and
this management concept though is the
thing that I see CEOs mess up more
consistently than anything else and from
when they're very very early to when
they're very very big as a company it's
it's the easiest thing to say and the
most difficult to master and the concept
in musical form looks hard me very
sensitive the musical form this is from
flying the family stone sometimes I'm
right and I can we run long believes are
in my song so the difference but group
I'm in so that's that's the musical
version and today's lesson for those of
your you musical you can leave now in
management concept form basically it's
this when you're making a critical
decision you have to understand how it's
going to be interpreted from all points
of view not just your point of view and
not just the person you're talking to
but the people who aren't in the room
everybody else in other words you really
have to be able when making critical
decisions to see the decision through
the eyes of the company and the company
as a whole which means you've got to
kind of add up every employees view and
then incorporate that into your own view
otherwise your management decisions are
going
very weird side effects and potentially
very dangerous consequences and it's a
really hard thing to do because at the
point when you're making a decision
you're often under a great deal of
pressure so let's get into the agenda so
I'm going to cover kind of four cases
first I'm going to cover demotions which
is a very emotional thing then raises
which is also an emotional thing then
we're going to evaluate one of Sam's
blog posts which is news to Sam so I
figured I teased him since he invited me
to do a 50-minute management class after
I wrote a 300 page book and then I'm
going to talk about history's greatest
practitioner at this and I'm wearing a
shirt with him on it and kind of how he
used it to do something that nobody has
done had ever done before in human
history and has never done since in
human history but basically complete
mastery of the technique I'm going to
talk about so first business example
you've got an executive and you demote
or do you fire him and this comes from
an actual conversation an actual
real-life situation that I was working
on with the CEO and so the basic
situation was this he had a great
executive or like an executive who just
a great effort like he hired him he was
working harder than anybody else in the
company doing you know like everything
it was supposed to everybody liked him
because he worked so hard and like as a
general smart person but he was just in
over his head knowledge wise he did not
have the knowledge and the skills to
basically do what the company needed him
to do or like really compete against the
competition so he could actually keep
him in the job but he's a great guy and
you know so the question is well should
I fire this person or can I just move
them into a lower role and bring in a
person above him and then like you know
that would be real cool so let's look at
how you kind of make that decision so
you and this in this case this is the
CEO so you as a CEO so one like look
it's really hard if
somebody comes to work every day like
you know at 6:00 a.m. and it's like
working till 10 p.m. and like doing it
like harder than anybody in the company
it's really hard to just say well sorry
like nice effort but you don't get me
for an effort you get NIF because I
fired you nobody nobody wants to have
that conversation and then a demotion is
kind of neat because from the CEOs point
of view and this is he's like look like
we can keep him in the company he worked
so hard he's a great example of like
somebody gives great effort and you know
like and then he's got a lot of friends
in the company and they're - you know
from a cultural standpoint like it's a
win-win because like he gets to stay and
and you know like and then I can bring
in somebody I can solve my problem but I
don't have to create another problem and
then if you think about it from the
executives perspective and what they
would think it's like well I you know I
want to be demoted but I really don't
want to be fired because if I get fired
that's a way harder more complicated
thing to explain to my next employer
then I got demoted like the commode it
is like well I really get two motors I
got a new job smaller title and then you
know the last thing is it enables you
know like theoretically well like you
know the company you know we value all
our employees we brought you in we made
a commitment to you as an employee and
like we value everybody and it kind of
will enable you to keep growing with the
company and so you know and this is the
kind of initial conversation I have with
a CEO and I said well wait a minute I
said let me ask you this like what is
the what's the equity package that this
exec has because well what do you mean I
was like well like this you have like a
director level compensation is we got
like a vice president level
conversations we have a point and a half
does he point four percent or what and
you know that kind of gave the CEO pause
he's like well he does have a point and
a half and I was like okay so you're an
engineer in your company how do you feel
about somebody who used to be the head
of sales who got brought in with a point
and a half now mind you you're a ninja
what
your engineers get like vegan 0.14 7.2%
what are they getting at this point so
how are they going to feel about
somebody who's not the head of sales
with 1.5% of the company he was like oh
and I was like yeah oh because like how
fair is that so are you going to take
the equity away are you up for doing
that or you up for going back and taking
back his compensation and like how
productive do you think he'll be if you
take away his compensation and then
secondly like will people give him the
same respect
now that you've demoted him because they
knew him as this and now he's this and
so like I knew you when you were head of
sales now you're the regional manager
and you're telling me what to do you're
telling me I need to make that call like
seems to me you got demoted you know who
are you to talk to me I'm the
up-and-comer I'll be the next VP of
Sales at the next company so all these
things come into play and so when you
look at at the end like you may think
you're dealing with one person you may
think that this is a demotion or a
firing of one person and what does it
mean according to that one person but
what you're really doing is you're
saying look what does it mean to fail on
the job particularly a very the highest
paid highest compensated job in the
company from an equity standpoint and
then like what's required to maintain
your equity like is it good enough to
put in effort where you have to get a
result and in different situations at
different levels like these answers will
come out differently and if this had
been a person not that was an executive
brought in from the outside but was
somebody who you may be promoted past
where they should have been and didn't
ever get that equity like maybe you make
a different decision but you've got to
understand what it's going to mean to
everybody not just the person you're
talking to example to an excellent
employee asks for a raise good employee
this isn't like a like the last employee
this is like really good employee so
excellent employee asks for a raise so
look your first thing is like they're
really good they ask me for a raise they
didn't ask me for an
no reason they asked me because they
think they deserve it I want to retain
them like I want to be fair they've done
a great job I want to be fair and like
you know I know that if I give them the
trays like it's going to be all love
coming my way it's going to be a
dragging you're raised we're good you
know like we're boys and you you've got
a raise
it's awesome so like you know from your
perspective you know what you want to do
when somebody asks you for a raise and
then if you look at it okay for what
about from their perspective what how
would they like take it if you gave them
at the race and now you have to remember
the employ from for them to get to the
point where they've asked you for a
raise this is not something they just
like woke up one morning and like I'm
going in and asking for a raise right
like this is something where they've
thought about it a lot they've you know
compared their other options they may
have an offer from another company you
know they're it's something their spouse
probably has been talking to them about
and so it's a serious thing and so if
you give it to them they're very likely
to feel very good about like they may be
like paranoid about like why you give me
raise but very unlikely much more
they'll feel like
[Music]
[Music]
I'm sorry I have to displace all things
and that's for those you don't know
that's bobby schmurder and rowdy rebel
doing the shmoney damn but that's that's
likely the reaction you'll get so
there's a lot of momentum to say yes
look you know they read Cheryl's book
they leaned in and I'm going to reward
them for for doing all that which is you
know and and by the way that book is
very good advice so I'm not knocking
Sheryl on that don't why should be
misinterpreting me however you know
there was going to be however what about
you have to think about it through the
point of view of the employee who did
not ask for the race so the employees
didn't ask for the race they may be
doing a better job than the employee he
did do ask for the race and in their
mind they're going okay so I didn't ask
for raise and I didn't get a raise and
they ask for a raise then they got a
raise and so what does that mean that
means one like you're not really
evaluating people's performance you're
just going well whoever asked get so
that means like I either need to be that
guy who asked for the raise like and you
know that's not how I feel you know like
I do my work and I don't necessarily
want to ask for a raise or like I just
need to quit and go to a company that
like actually evaluates performance and
then you know so you could really make
the person who doesn't get the raise
feel like pretty pissy about it and
don't think that when somebody is
walking down your company doing the
shmoney dance that other people aren't
going to notice like because they're
going to be fired up about that race
there's a you can say oh this is highly
confidential that I'm giving you this
race it's not confidential
and then the cultural conclusion is
going to be everybody in your company is
going to feel that they now have a
fiduciary responsibility to their family
to ask for a raise
all the time because if they don't then
they may be missing out on a raise that
they would have otherwise got and like
you talk to any experienced CEO and they
will tell you this is true like if you
give out raises when people just ask you
for them like that you will have a lot
of people asking you for raises that is
called encouraging behavior so what do
you do and really the right answer on
raises is you have to be formal and you
have to be formal to save your own
culture and I know this is always this
is the thing that causes people running
startups fit because it's like well I
don't want like a lot of formalities I
don't want a lot of process I want it to
be organic we want to do yoga we want
only smoke organic weed sorry that's
like a Peter Peter got very focused on
who is smoking weed a little while ago
but like the process actually protects
it protects the culture because what it
does is it says look we're going to look
at all the inputs we're going to have a
formal way of saying anybody who wants
to raise come talk to me like I'm not
going to give you a raise but I'm happy
to hear your story I'm going to talk to
all the people you work with so I get
like a understanding but I'm going to
evaluate all the work that you've done
so I know like where I actually write
you and what my actual opinion on though
I'm going to do that periodically I'm
not going to do it daily but like maybe
if I work fast-moving I'll do it every
six months or even maybe once a quarter
and at the end of that process I will
tell you what your raises and I will
tell you if you're getting one or if
you're not getting one but I'm not going
to do things off cycle I'm not going to
do things when asked there's like one
process and that's
and you know when I used to be CEO and I
had like executives it'sit's the bigger
you get the harder this gets because the
more aggressive the people working for
you are because to get to be an
executive it turns out you often have to
be pretty aggressive in this world and
in most companies like that's how you
get to that level you know I would go
look you can lobby me all you want you
know after the process is done and I
give you your raise but you know what
I'm not hearing it because I already
went through my process I got your input
going in I got everybody else's input
I've got so many people I've got so much
money and you got what like I believe is
right and having a process like that
basically gets people to be actually
more comfortable they're more
comfortable because they don't have to
always be on edge about like am I asking
for what I deserve or am I getting like
a stout because of Who I am what I look
like I'm not buddy-buddy I'm not at the
golf course with you or I'm not doing
whatever you like to do or you know I
don't have to worry about any of that
because I know your process I know your
process is like you're going to evaluate
everybody and then you're going to give
em what's fair and so that's a much
better way to handle that and it means
that you're actually understanding what
everybody thinks not just the people
you're talking to at the moment ok so
now we're going to get into some fun
stuff we're going to evaluate Sam's blog
post now which is actually there's some
very good things in it and then there's
some things I'm going to discuss so that
so this is the expert excerpt most
employees have only 90 days after they
leave a job to exercise their options
unfortunately this requires money to
cover the strike price and the tax bill
and I'll explain this a little more
later just but I want to read it first
for the year of exercise blah blah blah
this is often more cast an employee has
this is the key and so the employee
often has to choose between like leaving
the job and walking away from the vested
options ie the money that she has
because you can't afford to exercise or
being like locked in to staying at the
company basically for all the wrong
reasons it's a particularly bad
situation when employee gets terminated
and I'll get into that and that's a
really key point this doesn't seem fair
the best solution I have heard is from
Adam D'Angelo
a very very smart guy Acorah the idea is
to grant options that are exercisable
for 10 years from the grant date which
should cover nearly all the cases you
know whatever happens with the company
there are some tricky issues to this bla
bla bla but it's still far better than
just losing the assets I think this is a
policy that also startups should to debt
so our question is well like what Sam
right and is this a policy that all
startups at a depth so let me first
explain again what the policy is so
currently the way almost every stock
option package in Silicon Valley works
and in all the startup world is this
that your stock best you get stock at
best over a period of time but if you
leave the company when you leave you
have been it depends on the company but
I think it's 90 days to exercise so yeah
so 90 days and if you do not buy your
stock in that period sconed
like it's not yours anymore which
depending on when you entered the
company could be a big problem so a lot
of companies today's that are valued a
lot like if you take like a really
valuable startup like say an Airbnb or
an uber or something like that when they
bring you in they go wow you know like
if you look at your 409a price and to
the preferred price like the stock we're
giving you right now the options are
already worth like 10 million dollars
your life low ten million dollars from
rich but what they don't necessarily
tell you is in order for you to get that
money because they were the preferred is
worth 10 million dollars your options
probably are going to cost you like two
and a half million dollars when you
leave and if you don't have the two and
a half million dollars in 90 days it's
gone like you just lost all your money
and so Sam is like wow that's [ __ ] up
and so he wrote a blog post and he said
everybody should change it so the first
question that you have to ask yourself
on something like this is well why is
that even like this has kind of been
around since like the 80s so why is the
rule like this around for 30 years and
it turned out Sam and I don't even I
don't know whether he like figured this
out or just intuitive
but he was right like something actually
had changed so up until 2004 there used
to be this law called APB opinion number
25 that law was the old way to account
for stock options and you know it's also
the laws that all the guys went to jail
on so I got a lot of people who caught a
case on APB 25 so I'm glad it's gone
because it was a very confusing law and
a lot of people did not understand it
and they literally went to jail but when
that was the law if you gave somebody 10
years to exercise their options you
would never have been able to go public
and you would never have been able to be
acquired because you basically were
taking an expense that was tied to your
stock price so basically the more your
stock went up the more compensation
expense you'd have to take and the worst
thing about it would be is you wouldn't
know what it was going to be so be
totally unpredictable so you could never
forecast earnings ever because your
earnings would be a function of all of
your stock price and so the more your
stock price went up the more money you
would lose and in those days people did
not look through expect stock option
expenses so like it just wasn't doable
and that's why everybody's agreement was
written at 90 days so that's why it's
there so absolutely it's the right thing
to question it being now are you guys
following you get this this is like more
complicated than the first two examples
but a very important one okay then so
your perspective on this if you've got
employees did you want to be fair like
nobody wants like hey you get all the
stock in four years psyche right and
especially like when you fire someone
hey you're fired I feel real bad about
it but you know guess what I'm also
going to take all your money too
must not feel that bad so like that's
kind of like a problem but you also and
this is the thing that you've got to
keep in mind you also have to think
about the people who are staying and you
want to reward the people who are
staying now the employee the perspective
the employee leaves and this is really
critical because this is your reputation
right like I work like you know a year's
work like where's my year's pay and then
okay so now you're telling me about this
90 day exercise and I know it was in
like the fine print of my stock option
agreement but my hiring manager never
told me about that they never told me I
was going to need like two million
dollars to get my stock which I don't
have and like so if I was rich like I'd
get my stock like that's not fair and so
like you know now I'm fired and then I'm
screwed and guess what you know I'm
going to tell everybody like how you
like screwed me over and so that's a
real reputational problem so that's
something that you've got to consider in
selling this policy but then you also
have to consider the employee state and
one thing that they're going to ask
themselves is look they're leaving and
every time anybody leaves this is like
was that smart like that's something you
because these are people who write your
employees know each other better than
they know you in any company I don't
care what company you are but like often
like the person they're really working
with is going to be the person they know
more and so if that person leaves
they're going to go well like should
have I left to like what did they get
and how does that compare to my deal and
so like if we look at the situation and
we try and analyze it there's a lot of
components to it so first is like
companies to tread a lot of people
around here and I think like really the
average is somewhere around 10% it's
probably getting higher particularly if
you're in San Francisco it's getting
higher just because of the nature of the
culture there and then Silicon Valley
companies dilute like six eight or even
ten percent a year for employee options
and you have to keep in mind that is
mean as it may be if that employee
leaves and can
suicides their options then those
options come back to the pool where you
can potentially give them to people who
are already there so you're actually
taking less dilution so that's something
that you have to think about I'm not
saying you have to act on it but it's
something that you have to think about
it
then secondly look losing all your stock
is a very big incentive to stay and that
can be good news or bad news right like
it can be good news in that like you get
to keep somebody you might lost it can
be bad news and that you kept them for
the exact wrong reason right because
they have handcuffs on them and so you
know you may get like the exact place
where it's I'm not having it in play but
on the other hand a 10-year option on a
highly volatile security for those of
you have taken that class anybody taking
that class that's valuable right ten
years options are volatility and length
that's the value of an option well ten
years on a start-up stock that's a big
valuable thing and then remember the
employee stays doesn't get that
employees days just get the stock them
they get that but they don't get the new
job in the new stock so they get one
thing but they don't get both things and
so you've gotta weigh that in so this is
a hard one like I think that it should
be re-evaluated by every company I
wouldn't goes far it's the Sam that it
should be adopted by every company I
think you have to think about what you
want and I would just offer kind of two
alternative cultural statements one is
look we treat employees with the utmost
straightforwardness we're going to be
fair and therefore like you get 10 years
to exercise your stock and like what we
said we're going to give you you're
going to get regardless of how rich or
poor Yorick like that's just a done deal
the second way to handle it which is and
no companies do this which is why I
actually really like this post that he
wrote look you can say up front like
you're guaranteed to get your salary but
for your stock to be meaningful like
these are the things that have to happen
when you've got a vest - you have to
stay until like we get to an exit like
the company makes it and or like you've
got out of money and like finally like
the company's actually got to be worth
something because
10% and nothing is nothing and look the
reason that we set the policy this way
is like we really value people who stay
so don't join this company like if
you're going to join another one in 18
months because like you're going to get
screwed and like our policy like
guarantees you're going to get screwed
on that and so like those are two ways
to handle it it really depends on like
you and how you want to run your culture
but again with all these things it's
just critical to think it through from
everybody's perspective because when
push comes to shove that's going to
matter it's going to change the outcome
of your company let's hear it I think I
need to be more than today
right so you put at it look at out of
say incentive it's all me fire nestled
in a screwed oh well the other and the
other thing that's really important that
Sam pointed out is like the distinction
now is how much money you have right if
you've got the money you don't get
screwed you walk away with all you can
buy your stock you do take some risk but
you can buy your stock if you don't have
the money you don't have the money okay
so now we're getting to the percent on
my shirt Toussaint he was the best at
this and I want to take you through some
examples because they're very powerful
okay so first of all about Toussaint he
was born the same time extend about him
is he was born a slave and but he wasn't
a foreign a slave he was born a slave in
the most brutal place to be a slave
which was in kind of the then the colony
of Santo Domingo you know now referred
to as Haiti but this was actually a much
more severe form of slavery as were kind
of all the sugar growing areas then even
US slavery which is historically a very
brutal form of slavery and just to give
you some numbers on it basically over
the course of slavery the sum of 400
years a million slaves were brought to
the US and at the end of slavery there
were four million slaves in the u.s. in
that same period - the sugar growing
countries in the Caribbean
two million slaves were brought over and
at the end of slavery there were 700,000
so from just a quantitative perspective
like nearly ten times more brutal and
I'm going to read this to you I don't
know if I quite have time but I don't
care so but just to give you an idea
this isn't just like a quantitative
thing I'll read you sort of a
description of slavery in Tucson Syria
whipping was interrupted in order to
pass a piece of hot wood on the buttocks
of the victim salt pepper citron cinders
aloes and hot ashes were poured into
bleeding wounds it's not to heal them
just to make it worse
mutilations were common limbs ears and
sometimes private parts to deprive them
of the pleasures would say could indulge
without expense their masters poured
burning wax on their arms and hands and
shoulders emptied the boiling cane sugar
over their heads burning them alive
roasted them onto slow fires filled them
with gunpowder and blew them up with a
match buried them up to their neck and
smear their heads with sugar that the
Flies might devour them fastened them to
the nest of ants or wasps and made them
eat their extra mint drink their urine
lick saliva of other slaves one colonist
was known in moments of anger to throw
himself on his slaves and stick his
teeth into their flesh so that's the
slavery that he grew up in and it's
really important to understand this
because to get out of that perspective
was not easy but he had a vision and his
vision was kind of threefold one he
wanted to end slavery - he wanted to
actually take control of the country and
run the country and thirdly he wanted it
to be a first-class world-class country
not just like something that where he
had freed the slaves but something that
could compete on a worldwide basis and
so that was his mindset going in but
that was a background that he came from
so example management example one
conquering the enemy so the kind of
sequence of battles that occurred in
Haiti were first you know he has to kind
of defeat the locals but then once he
defeated the locals which is there were
several countries that were very very
interested in taking control of Haiti
principally Spain England and France so
we had to defeat those armies as well
when he
awkward them he had to decide what to do
with the kind of Concord soldiers and
the leaders on the other side and to do
this he really took into perspective
kind of three different points of view
one his soldiers point of view to the
enemy's point of view and finally the
point of view of the resulting culture
like what kind of country was he
building because the army was going to
be the seed corn for the culture of the
whole country so from the soldiers
perspective and I get this you know do
we get spillage like soldiers like to
pillage they get stuff it's something
for their work and like the second thing
is they're trying to kill us so we
should kill them like that's a basic
perspective of the people who are
fighting for him so the most important
people to thought now I put pillage up
there and a couple of things to know
when I input rape up there and very
interestingly like not only did he not
allow rape among his army but he didn't
even allow his officers to cheat on
their wives and if they did he'd get rid
of them because he was so concerned
about the resulting culture what was it
going to be was it going to be
productive was it going to be best in
world or was it going to be something
less than that and so that's that was
his mindset going in his army was
actually famous for not pillaging so
they were actually already used to
disable famous for not till a'junk and
this was a one of the most surprising
things to the conquered people to the
point where in Haiti he had a reputation
where even the white people were like
very impressed with him just because he
would go in and go into their city in
that pillage even though he would win
but again this is because he took a long
view of the culture so and this is a
kind of important subtle point which
gets into his conclusion but he believed
that the culture of Haiti because it was
a slave culture sugar plantation culture
was just pretty low-grade to what he had
experienced in Europe when he dealt with
the Europeans and then he thought that
slave culture was even more broken than
Haitian culture because if you think
about slave culture it's like the kind
of culture where oh you don't do what
you I'm going to beat you to death I'm
going to blow you up with gunpowder if
you think the kind of behavior that that
then that ensues from that that was the
culture he knew he needed to replace he
mean he knew he needed to upgrade so his
solution was when he conquered the
British for he conquered the Spanish
where he conquered the French he would
take the very best people from there and
he would make them generals in his army
so we probably didn't expect that like
so here the guy's trying to kill him
he's leading a slave revolution and he
when he conquered the enemy he actually
incorporates them into his army and
makes him part of that because he wanted
the expertise and he wanted the he
wanted the culture to be at a much
higher level so the second question he
had does the more complicated what do
you do with the slave owners so you're
leaving slave revolution you take
control the country what do you do with
the slave owners three perspectives
again so for the slaves like come on
like if you're a slave and you win the
war against the slave owners like you
want to kill them there is no question
Emily do you want to kill them but like
that's your land now like we won like fu
from Tucson perspective it was more
complicated because he wanted Haiti to
be a first world country and sugar was
really important and the whole slave
economy was the sugar economy then right
like on the other hand he was a slave
and he's got to be pretty upset
particularly given the type of slavery
then he had but he had to consider like
he didn't know how to run a cigar
plantation and then like he didn't have
any business relationships on who to
trade the sugar with but on the other
hand like like war like you win the war
you get the land like that's a pretty
like basic rule so what to do and then
if you look at the slave owner
it's pretty interesting because they're
coming at it from the and this is a
point of view that he actually had the
discipline to understand they were
coming from a cause structure that was
predicated on slave labor so like their
business didn't work without slave labor
like literally if they had to pay people
like their cash flow wouldn't work they
paid a lot of money for the slaves up
front and they paid a lot of money for
the land so in their mind like to run it
like that was like that's how business
work like you can't just you can't just
like change the economics and have it
still work and then they knew they had
like some power because of the position
they were in so what was the answer for
the slave owners so one so the solution
was like one I'm going to end slavery to
I'm going to let the flavor nerds keep
their land 3 I'm going to make them pay
their workers so they're no more slave
labor you have to have paid workers but
in order to fund that I'm going to lower
their taxes you guys ought to be kind of
impressed with that like lower the taxes
of the slave owners after you defeat the
slave owners and like end slavery but he
had a bigger goal he wanted a stronger
culture the way he treated those slave
owners they need to keep the economy
going was important and then like let's
look at the results so first of all it
is to thoughts revolution is the only
successful slave revolution in the
history of mankind there has never been
another one there may never hopefully we
won't have slavery in a big way and
there won't be another one so like he's
it to give the plantation owners kept
their land 3 he defeated Napoleon he had
a booming economy in a world-class
culture under Toussaint Haiti had more
exports export revenue than the United
States so that's not successful he was
in the revolution and this is the power
of looking at a situation not just from
your point of view but from the point of
view of all the constituents even the
people you hate which is hard to do when
you're CEO and harder to do when you're
leading a revolution so just like in
conclusion the most important
that you can learn as CEO the one of the
hardest things to do is you have to
discipline yourself to see your company
through the eyes of the people that
you're working through through the eyes
of the employees through the eyes of
your partner's through the eyes of the
people who you're not talking to and who
are not in the room Thank You Thomas how
to communicate alleged selected
employees for the map because of the
accessibility phase right right this is
a great question yes so the question is
so if you've got a fire demote an
executive one how do you have the
conversation and then to like how do you
explain it to everyone else because like
it's clearly some kind of failure you
failed on hiring you failed on
integrating they failed at their job
like some like its failure and so I'd
say look the first thing is when firing
the person you have to really try to be
honest and you know you're feeling like
you failed and I think a common reaction
is like there's a couple of common
reactions one is like you just suck and
like so like I'm firing you screw off
that's not good because it's not really
true it may be like you know you're
feeling that way and then another kind
of common mistake is just to be like you
know too mushy it's not you it's me and
it like feels like some kind of weird
breakup with an ex-boyfriend that you
really didn't like but generally like
when you hire people like you try to
hire the very best and you hire people
who are qualified to do the job and
generally the reason that they fail in
the job is you made some mistake in the
hiring process in that you didn't match
them to the needs of your company
accurately enough that's the number one
reason why this fails and so that's
generally a good place to start to say
look here's here's how we are and here's
what I didn't recognize about us and
about you when I made the decision and
now like it is what it is
so we're going to have to move on and
then when you talk to the employees
about it like this is and this gets
different which is look you can take
somebody's job you have to take their
job and this is something Bill Campbell
taught me but you don't have to take
their dignity and so it's not necessary
to get up in front of the company so I
blew that [ __ ] out I capped his
ass in fact it's not good because
somebody feels good about that like you
know you might feel like proud of
yourself but like nobody else feels good
about that you know the right thing to
do is just look thank them for their
work like let people know that they're
moving on and you don't really have to
explain all their personal details it's
more important to leave them with their
dignity and like let them go on to live
another day because look what you say at
that meeting that's their reputation
because everybody in your company is
going to get a call on that person when
they try and get their next job so if
you start saying like a bunch of BS
about them like that's not going to be
good and it's not going to get
interpreted it's like we screwed up it's
going to get interpreted as you know he
screwed up and so there are kind of two
different things you have to be very
honest with them but you have to make
sure you preserve their dignity when you
talk to the company yes sir I am sorry
about that bit yeah will not smell it
elsewhere
and the one person I think when was how
do you is the teachers that were bold
and stressed like meditating
the question was how did I deal with all
the stress of being CEO and the answer
is I used to be six foot four and
good-looking so clearly not very well I
could ask that a lot and I really don't
have a great answer for it I mean I
think that the one I have a wonderful
wife who's sitting right here so I say
that so if you're married to somebody if
you're married to somebody who's
supportive that makes it like a thousand
times easier if I did not if I wasn't I
would definitely probably be dead but
but the one thing with dress is you've
got to keep your focus on what you can
do not what happened to you and that's a
it's a really hard thing to do because
it's constantly kind people are always
asking you about it like what the [ __ ]
are we going to do we're going to die
we're running out of cash going to be
over soon but you can't focus on that
you have to focus on okay like what are
my options what can I do and where can I
go and the better that you are at that
the kind of higher your chances for
success
August's I can get the same dinners who
will say what was this [ __ ] so so this
is great question how did his aunt get
the French generals to work for him and
the reason was they were so shocked that
he didn't kill them because he was like
where their perspective is we're
fighting the slave army we're fighting
the savage army they're going to kill us
and so when he said look we're not going
to kill you that was such a shock to
their system that a completely
reoriented their whole way of thinking
and they actually became much more loyal
to him than they ever were to France and
he actually borrowed that technique
interestingly from Julius Caesar who he
had studied he was a very unusual slave
in the sense that his his owner
recognized how smart he was and put him
in the library because he wanted to
Sante eventually run the plantation for
him and so the person that he studied
most of all in his mouth
since library was Julius Caesar and so
he borrowed that technique from him but
applied in a much kind of more dramatic
context and so his army was kind of he
had British French Spanish slaves and
mulatos who most of the mulatos in Haiti
at that time were pro-slavery so that
was another issue but he his leadership
was so great everybody wanted to join
hi-yah how do you incorporate that same
ideology who were feeding on your side
yeah so you know and it's different in
different ways but a lot of it you know
his whole strategy and I'm sorry the
question was how do you get people how
do you incorporate Toussaint's ideology
and get people who are previously
against you on your side and I would
just say like what he did in general is
is the right thing which is to basically
you have to show them a better way you
know as a leader if somebody's your
enemy and you need to convert them over
and this happens in business to where
like somebody's like out of competitors
something and you want to bring them
over but you want to bring them over you
know you don't want to bring bring all
the unethical people who will switch
competitor to competitor over and it
really is like your culture has to be
elevated your mission has to be elevated
your way of doing things has to be just
better and that was the thing that was
so compelling for for the other rest of
the army
yes great this is sort of like a
tradition of always like be seeing
and how people with a culture of people
no longer being with that sort of
differentiate you in the market from
laws probably not the best question for
me I could ask them that I don't know so
the question is you know how we build a
culture at Andreessen Horowitz that has
differentiated us from all of their VPS
I feel like you know that's certainly
the goal and you know we've been around
for five years now and you know the
attempt that we made at it and you know
for the rest of the world to judge if we
succeeded was basically this fad you
know in the old days of BC when I was an
entrepreneur the basic idea was like
you'd have an entrepreneur inner
inventor and they'd get a company to a
point and then at that point they'd
either be like ready to be CEO or you
would go find a CEO to replace them and
build quote-unquote the company our kind
of cultural philosophy was look the
founder inventor is special so we're
going to design the firm and the culture
of the firm to help the founder develop
into a CEO and so we do a lot of
systematic things different
the two biggest are one all of our
partners are kind of founder CEOs so
that you get somebody who were original
model with some experience required it's
a joke
if you advise the CEO you have to have
kind of been a CEO imagine that that's
why I like Sam used to be a CEO he
doesn't talk about it that much but he
he was a CEO and I'm good at it and then
the second part is that a professional
CEO would bring in in the old days is a
network of just tons of people that he
would know from like all kinds of you
know guys who bought technology at big
corporations to like important partners
in the field like guys like Google on
Facebook - you know people in the press
that he or she might know and so forth
and so we try to basically build that
Network on your behalf of the firm and
we probably I think we do a better job
of that than anybody else so that those
are the way that that we try to be
different
yes one more question yes the front row
is why are we here talking others
will shoot very hard see maximum so can
you give us belts it's too late in life
yeah yeah so putting yourself in other
people's shoes is difficult in
management can you think about how to do
in daily life it's hard it's hard in
daily life it's even harder and
management because it's the stress of
the moment right like a great employee
is asking you for a raise it is very
hard not to respond it's it's a very
because like you do not want to lose
them and like they're not asking you for
a raise randomly they're asking you
erase for a reason and so to say okay
you know pretty good if you don't have a
process in place to go stop like back
out yeah I would just say the yeah and
it's a key thing in being a leader is
you've got to pause yourself like if
somebody comes to you with something
that you know is important but you want
to feel like you know when you're a
leader you want to feel like you have
all the answers like right now you guys
are asking me questions if I don't know
the answer I'll make something up
because I want you to think I'm real
smart and it's important I say the most
important thing is to pause like so if
you know something is really important
and you haven't thought it through just
to say you know look I'm taking this
really seriously but I have to pause
because I have to think it through from
all perspectives and I'm going to come
back and I've end up doing that a lot
just because there are a lot of things
that you run into that you haven't seen
before and I'll tell you you know most
CEOs including myself wearing this the
hard way you walk in you kind of step in
it like three or four times you go okay
I'm going to sneak away with this
nobody's going to see me give them the
raise I'm going to do it and this could
be all under the cover is
confidentiality baby and then like it
comes up in and blows up in your face
three weeks later and you're like oh my
god like what have I done or three
months late or even a year later and
then you know what it's a year later
it's a huge problem like so you've taken
what's a little emotion
problem and you've turned it into a
forest fire you know we call it like the
kimchi problem the deeper you bury it
the hotter it gets the Korean Jo but but
you know it takes practice it takes
practice it's very difficult to do and I
say you know like some of the my friend
Bill Campbell this is his big skill like
this is what he's so great at people
always try and describe him to me and
I'm like that's not him at all that's
not what he's good at
like he's not good at that or that he's
good at this he's good at seeing the
company through the eyes of the
employees and it's like I said if you if
you're good at that you'll be in a very
likely and elite leader so thank you
thank you
[Applause]
you